I miss traveling with anyone
hell yeah [ __ ] I wonder how the whole
travel industry is gonna change because
remember after 9/11 that's when they
introduced TSA and so that's when things
got crazy
I wonder how crazier things medico si
will screen your health I think so and
that's you gotta go to TSA and you gotta
go to [ __ ] hell 'this a fever check
HSN you walked into the scanner also
check your temperature or something I
think they're gonna put the seat six
feet apart finally get more legroom they
can't give it to us they hate us too
much they decreased legroom they did a
lot but I'm glad you brought of airplane
seats because this one Italian
manufacturing firm they have unfilled
but you laugh I love cuz I was picturing
us being like hey do we finally get more
legroom and the airlines like actually
we discovered a way we're giving you
less legroom but we're having you wear
this mask the whole time and we're just
like okay we take it up the ass anyway
we really can't yes airline here I mean
a company they they ended up mocking up
some concepts like future airline seats
of help they could possibly blow [ __ ]
after this whole pandemic well I don't
want to be facing somebody to hold a
[ __ ] trip dude you don't know who
they are but it's even closer to it's
like this close a little bit further
back hey there's another one where we're
just like or like so they can see it on
the screen we're just like this
no they see me there's a guy the guy in
the middles like this like this if you
let another guy yeah I'm sitting right
here two guys
like this Oh like this like this worse
Joe sneezes right he sneeze in on that's
true because they have these like
protective barrier so these are like
walls and they're saying that they have
them in different capacities yeah so
this is what the concept like one of
their concepts is and then this is like
the overhead view but why they making
people face each other because it's like
space is better for germs
yeah it's so you have less like
closeness or whatever you gotta climb
into your seat how do you get out
there's a wall there
and how do you sleep exactly like how do
you recline in [ __ ] and if you need a
pee you gotta climb back out I guess
yeah this no thank you
a lot of people are like how would you
get your food or your drink or whatever
but just slide it under currently right
now there's a lot of airlines that
completely stopped the in-flight
services because so they want to protect
the the air attendants fight possess
[Laughter]
well happen to a good old days when they
used to be hot I was born you know
before you were born I know they were
stewardesses there trying to protect
them so they have minimized a lot of the
services that they offer on flights and
then also certain flights like for
example Delta they are completely
prohibiting booking the middle seats
altogether create some distance that's
so cool I love it when nobody sits next
to me yeah I wasn't there gonna do that
until things slowly go back to normal
yeah or that might be the new norm like
who knows just remove it altogether
that's good yeah cuz then like so that
makes me want to fly more yeah dude I
love seeing a packed first class and
then in the back like we're all like
have one row to ourselves I'm like [ __ ]
you [ __ ] we've been I'm like the
people want this one
that is with us but yes so here's
another concept where this concept here
is it's like an attachment to existing
seats so that like barriers I could get
your hair dry can you imagine place on
it so then like it's like this like
attachment yeah where it kind of has
like a little bit like of a hood when
they said Italian I was expecting a
little bit more gaudy in the style you
know a little bit more Caesar's Palace
you look well we have actually tough so
this particular firm has made headlines
in the past because they were
responsible for creating this concept or
like banding air airline seats but it's
a concept though that guy likes it I
don't know he's like a rapport he's
banned from the Asian race you know what
though some of those flights in in
Europe are just like an hour long so
maybe for that maybe it's better that
way and they're cheap already dude
they're like 20 bucks for a [ __ ]
plane ticket becomes like five dollars
maybe if that was the case but I would
much rather opt out for the Train out
there he's like this is how we always
stand in Asia really really close to
each other that's true Moz will be up
against the wall and I'm in a carnival
right like at that point that's
crazy-looking yeah we're like that one
right at six legs oh yeah you're like
standing the whole time yeah Riddler is
revenge
Riddler's revenge I wonder if it's still
there I wonder I wonder if any amusement
parks will open for a long time like
Disney and all this are they getting
crushed definitely well yeah they're
probably losing like 10 million dollars
a day that they're not being open and
then the whole community so all of
Anaheim is built to support Disney
pretty much there's just rows of hotels
right like they count on that the
tourism and that industry and like yeah
that whole city is rush Las Vegas itself
is [ __ ] I was watching this video on all
the industries that are non-essential
and the ones that are getting hit the
most well the first one is tourism and
they're saying like the whole city of
Las Vegas because it's all entertainment
casinos restaurants service industries
all those they're getting hit the
hardest maybe it now is a good time to
buy a house there pretty soon in a
couple years maybe
so Vegas this trying to open up right
now yeah the mayor came out since why
made headlines same time like even if
you do open up are people gonna come
you're coming firstly think about it all
people all the people that want to get
the hell out of the house and their
their state and their whatever they're
just like well I'm I think I'm gonna go
over there but we're gonna go in droves
to [ __ ] Vegas I don't know if you'll
be able to fill it up though I wonder
because there's so many people were
thinking about being around other people
yeah I don't know but there's also a lot
of people that just want to get the hell
out of the house like for example
Florida they don't give a [ __ ] out there
you see as soon as they opened up the
beach again you see the picture they
just went right out they didn't give a
[ __ ] they're opening our beaches this
weekend but Ventura County really that's
like off you're not about to station so
you can't have like a picnic or a tent
you're allowed to walk and visit it now
so they're just opening it up and faces
runner out on the beach you go run on
the beach if you want but you can't sit
down and take it I feel like they should
do this once a month for every year
because of how it's helping nature
self-isolation thing I agree the traffic
has been awesome and just running I
don't smell smog yeah I love it
coverage in Venice Italy how there's
like jellyfish in the canals now you can
actually see and like the water is like
kind of getting clearer what are you
doing those port canals they're [ __ ]
in them every day the bows are always
there something like a lot of light
because all the tourists around the
canals they probably throwing [ __ ] in
there all the time
nature just needs like a little break
every every time to reset once a month
yeah that's right
like I kind of feel like cuz you know
they always say like nature balances
itself and stuff and like this
everything that's happening right now
all the humans are like the least nature
thing ever so we just we destroy that we
came from nature yeah well that's once a
long time ago was like oh I'm gonna
force your hand in [ __ ] balancing
this so mother nature made Cove it'd
happen cuz they're like mother nature is
like I need to get rid of this parasite
that's sucking me out but Mother
Nature's [ __ ] us up all the time dude
mother nature is like you'll hear the
hurricane [ __ ] you guys in Tennessee
that's good
they didn't wipe out or nothing of us oh
yeah she was like I need something
strong she's always attacking us dude
I'm too nice and we fight back fingers I
do we replace mother we replace quaint
earth with metal and [ __ ] it's time to
fight back against the sick of it
hurricane yeah fought wildfires and
tornado
look what Mother Earth just did the
[ __ ] Australia any more plastic Oh
follow me mother nature created humans
yeah mother earth could have had an ice
storm going over there true modern
nature if mother earth is this cogent
[ __ ] being who can do things cuz
she's she's you know mother earth how
come she doesn't do nice things very
much she does she gave us a paradise we
[ __ ] it she did she gave us a paradise
that has volcanoes earthquakes tornadoes
hurricane you what's mother earth done
for us recently not much and that's good
yeah mother earth didn't make us video
games huh Wow she gives us her kids
Hurricane Katrina
you entitled Brett this is if I'm
[ __ ] successful businessman look at
me and then mother nature's out here
going I'll give you guys every [ __ ]
sunset what's your problem really [ __ ]
this [ __ ] man not giving us anything
I see two sunset every single night it
gets boring that's the same you got to
change it up make it green or something
yeah make it something [ __ ] purple
yeah
give us another moon may get more purple
more perfect it's too predictable yeah
lavender mother nature should have
thought of it [ __ ] that's what the
hurricane is for it I guess but it's
hurricane sunsets do look nice yeah
Katie you tell me what's a tornado for
other than being a human and cow killing
machine or a house lifter yeah it's the
event it's a circulating the air in the
air it's the test your bathtubs you see
how well it's welded into the ground the
plumbing says I like the spinny spins or
it's a portal to get to the
go see scared world it spins around
pretty nice if you're a fan of spirals
that's the only doodle I mean spirals
it's the only one that I've ever doodles
is the tornado to me Oh doodle you could
be in a bathtub and get thrown in it tip
of a guy gets struck by lightning or you
like mother nature struck back yeah
mother nature knows something about you
that we don't know you should have been
standing there
why are you wearing metal because it's
blingy blingy hell yeah shoutout to
james vita from todd jewelers let us
borrow his bling on this side we just
represent the common folk no common folk
blue-collar
[Laughter]
well he's white collared
well you guys are no college I would
offer you guys one of my chains to have
several chains but I earned these chains
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]